Republican senator Tim Scott recently
preached at a church I accidentally
called him Pastor Tim Scott the other
day and during that preaching he said
that actually contrary to what you might
read in the Constitution he says the
Constitution demands that the government
bow before the church we are supposed to
have the government bowing the knee to
the church not the church bowing the
knee to the government now of course
that's wrong but Tim Scott is doing
something very calculated here Tim Scott
is considering launching a Republican
Presidential candidacy challenging
Donald Trump and uh Vivek ramaswamy and
Nikki Haley okay ASA Hutchinson and part
of the calculus for Tim Scott is can he
Pander directly to the Evangelical
voters